Hace casi 50 años, en 1969, el aquel momento
presidente de Estados Unidos, Richard Nixon
anunció y puso en marcha la conocida como
“Guerra contra las drogas”;
una estrategia de mano dura que tenía como
objetivo perseguir y castigar la producción,
la distribución y el consumo de sustancias
consideradas como drogas prohibidas.
Desde entonces, amigos, a pesar de que Washington
ha hecho uso de toda su fuerza, esta estrategia
de mano dura se ha saldado con un estrepitoso
fracaso… tanto dentro como fuera de casa.
Fijaos, cada año el gobierno de Estados Unidos
gasta decenas de miles de millones de dólares
en esta particular guerra sin conseguir prácticamente
nada más que encarcelar a cientos de miles
de personas y alimentar con ello la cultura de
la violencia.
Las cifras del gobierno federal sobre arrestos
por violar las leyes antinarcóticos ponen
los pelos de punta.
Cada año las autoridades de Estados Unidos
detienen a más de 1 millón de personas,
¡1 millón de personas!
Por quebrantar las leyes anti-droga.
Es decir, dicho de otra forma, en 10 años
EEUU detiene por delitos relacionados con las drogas
a tanta gente como
toda la población de Bolivia o Cuba… que
se dice pronto.
Desde 1989, atentos, porque el dato es realmente
sorprendente, en Estados Unidos han sido encarceladas
más personas por este tipo de delitos que
por todos los demás crímenes violentos juntos.
De hecho, esto es, precisamente, lo que ha
provocado que este país tenga, ojo, la tasa
de encarcelamiento más alta del mundo, 4
o 5 veces mayor que la de países como Francia
o Alemania y más alta, incluso, que la países
totalitarios como China.
¡De locos!
(Por supuesto, como os podéis imaginar…
las cárceles de Estados Unidos no son precisamente
el mejor sitio del mundo para rehabilitarse.
De hecho, la experiencia norteamericana parece
decir todo lo contrario.
Las cárceles estadounidenses son la mejor
academia para aprender a delinquir.)
Pero… puede que estéis pensado… vale,
Enrique, puede que sea una estrategia dura…
pero tal vez esté cumpliendo su propósito
¿verdad?
Pues… lo cierto es que no. Más allá de abarrotar
las cárceles, gastar cientos de miles de
millones, y condenar la vida de muchísimos
jóvenes que
tienen muy difícil reincorporarse
a la vida normal tras pagar muy caro sus errores,
esta guerra contra las drogas
ha conseguido muy poco, practicamente
nada.
(De hecho, a pesar de tantos “esfuerzos”,
Estados Unidos sigue teniendo una de las mayores
tasas de consumo de drogas de todo el mundo.
Hoy esta tasa es incluso mayor que en los
años 80.)
Y respecto a sus resultados fuera de Estados
Unidos… qué os voy a contar.
Los que nos estáis viendo desde Latinoamérica,
estoy seguro, lo sabéis muy bien.
Porque…amigos… una cosa sí ha conseguido
esta “guerra contra las drogas”:
hacer de oro a muchos narcotraficantes.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Toda esta estrategia de prohibición y mano
dura contra las drogas ha hecho que este negocio
sea extremadamente lucrativo… casi una mina
de oro, que ha enriquecido a narcos, pandillas
y carteles, al tiempo que ha sembrado la violencia
por toda América Latina.
(“El cartel de la cocaína no comienza en
Medellín, Colombia.
Comienza en las calles de Nueva York, Miami,
Los Ángeles y en cada una de las ciudades
estadounidenses donde se vende y compra crack”.
Nancy Reagan.”)
Pero… un momento, amigos, porque tras tantos
fracasos… hoy una nueva estrategia está
está en marcha en Estados Unidos… y
de momento sus resultados parecen
prometedores.
¿Habéis oído hablar de la industria de
la marihuana?
Pues atentos.
EL GRAN CAMBIO
El pasado 1 de enero de 2018, California,
se convirtió en el octavo territorio de Estados Unidos
en legalizar la producción, la distribución
y el consumo de marihuana para uso recreativo.
El uso médico ya lo habían aprobado en 1996.
(Además de California, Alaska, Colorado,
Massachusetts, Maine, Washington y Nevada
son los otros estados, donde junto a la capital,
Washington D.C., el uso recreativo de la marihuana
es perfectamente legal.
Por su parte, el estado de Vermont acaba de
anunciar que a partir del 1 de julio, la posesión
y el consumo también serán legales)
Ojo, porque hablamos de una cambio muy, pero
que muy importante.
Sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta que la legislación
federal, como luego veremos, lo sigue considerando
una actividad prohibida.
Pues bien, el pasado año esta nueva industria
movió, legalmente, casi 7.000 millones de
dólares, una cifra que se espera suba con
fuerza en los próximos años, sobre todo
porque tan solo el mercado de California se
estima en más de 5.000 millones.
Hablamos, amigos, de toda una industria que
ya está generando muchísimos empleos y que
también está pagando muchos impuestos.
Y, ojo, no solo nos referimos a la venta de marihuana
para consumo directo, también están surgiendo
un montón de nuevos negocios que aprovechan
este ingrediente para producir todo tipo de cosas,
(“Nosotros vendemos dulces, galletas, caramelos;
tenemos cientos de productos.
Es un negocio de muchísimos dólares y el
estado se queda con el 25% de cada dólar
que facturamos”.
Eric Kinney, dueño de Zen West Hollywood.)
Como es fácil de entender, los estados que
han legalizado esta industria, la han considerado
un tanto especial, así que han fijado importantes
regulaciones e impuestos.
Y las ciudades, y los condados han hecho básicamente
lo mismo.
La regulación establece quién puede vender,
cómo y dónde puede hacerlo o cuánto tiene
que pagar por ello.
(“Es como cualquier otra industria fuertemente
regulada.
Mira la industria farmacéutica o la industria
del licor.
Son industrias fuertemente reguladas, y la
industria del cannabis no es diferente ".
Cara Martinson, Directora para Asuntos Federales
de la Asociación de Condados del Estado de California.
Y no es algo precisamente barato.
En algunas ciudades de California, la suma
de todos los impuestos puede llegar a suponer
cerca del 40% de la facturación de estas
nuevas empresas… qué se dice pronto.
En Colorado, el primer estado que legalizó
la venta y el consumo de marihuana para uso
recreativo, la industria factura ya cerca
de 1000 millones de dólares cada año, y
los ingresos en impuestos para el estado superan
los 200 millones.
(“Entre los ocho Estados donde la marihuana
recreacional es legal, Washington tiene la
tasa de impuestos más alta, alrededor de
50%.
Colorado y Nevada siguen con tasas del 36%.
Oregon tiene una tasa de impuestos del 20%
y Alaska tiene una tasa de hasta un 20%.”
Aaron Smith, reportero de la CNN.)
Sin embargo, amigos, esperad un momento, porque
aquí no termina todo.
Digamos que...hay… un problema, un problema
bastante serio.
Como os he dicho antes, la ley federal de
Estados Unidos sigue considerando que esto
es una actividad prohibida… lo que hace
que este tipo de negocios, por ejemplo,  tengan muy difícil,
por no decir imposible obtener
créditos de entidades financieras.
Claro, un banco que financiase a estas empresas podría llegar a ser acusado,
incluso, de colaborar con el narcotráfico.
Y no solo eso.
(Veréis, hasta ahora, estaba en vigor una
política puesta en marcha por la Administración
Obama, que digamos hacía que el Departamento
de Justicia le pidiera a los fiscales federales
que no presentaran cargos cuando la producción,
venta y consumo de droga fuese legal conforme
a las leyes de los estados.)
Pues bien, esta política, conocida como el
“memorando Cole” ha sido suspendida por
Jeff Sessions, el Fiscal General nombrado
por Donald Trump.
Este fiscal ha anunciado que quiere perseguir
los negocios de marihuana… Algo que por
cierto, Trump, prometió en campaña que no
iba a hacer.
Así que ahora toda esta nueva industria…
se encuentra sumergida en un mar de mucha
incertidumbre… ¿Cumplirá el Fiscal General
sus deseos?
¿Atacará la Administración Trump a la industria
de la marihuana?
Estas son las preguntas que están sobre la
mesa y que solo el futuro nos podrá responder.
De momento, amigos, lo que si podemos hacer
es fijarnos en por qué ese cambio de planteamiento
podría ser un gran error.
(CAMBIO DE CLAVE.)
Han pasado ya unos cuantos años desde que
en 2014 Colorado se convirtió en el primer
estado en legalizar el uso recreativo de la
marihuana.
Como hemos visto en este tiempo se han sumado
unos cuantos estados más, así que ya podemos
analizar qué ha ocurrido… qué consecuencias
ha tenido esta nueva política.
Veréis, en aquel momento, los críticos con
la legalización dijeron que los riesgos de
permitir el consumo recreativo del cannabis
eran muy altos.
Por ejemplo, decían que probablemente crecería
el consumo entre los menores, crecería la
delincuencia o se dispararían los accidentes
de tráfico.
Pues bien ahora ya podemos ver qué es lo
que ha ocurrido… y lo cierto es que los
resultados no han tenido nada que ver con
esas catastróficas predicciones.
Ni se ha incrementado la violencia, ni el
consumo entre menores, ni tampoco los accidentes
de tráfico.
De hecho, si algo ha tenido la legalización
han sido consecuencias positivas…
Por un lado, ha mejorado la calidad del producto
que se vendía en el mercado negro y también
ha reducido en estos estados el consumo de
algunas sustancias más peligrosas.
(La legalización de la marihuana para uso
recreacional ha dado a los consumidores estadounidenses
acceso a la marihuana de alta calidad, con
cepas mejoradas genéticamente, cultivadas
en invernaderos",
Raúl Benitez-Manaut, experto en guerra de drogas de la Universidad Nacional Autónoma de México.
Y, ojo, porque esto es muy importante.
Hace unos años el Cato Institute publicó
un estudio que determinaba, atentos, que 8
de cada 10 muertes producidas por las drogas
se debían a la mala calidad del producto.
Eso es un problema social… una tragedia.
Vamos a ver, el consumo, salvo uso medicinal,
nunca es bueno, eso que quede claro, pero
la demanda existe por lo que mejorar la calidad
y la seguridad del producto permite reducir
el daño causado.
Pero… aún hay más.
La legalización también está reduciendo,
como es lógico, el negocio de los cárteles,
y por tanto, el dinero que reciben estos grupos
mafiosos.
Y, además, y este es tal vez el efecto más
importante, ha permitido que las detenciones
relacionadas con el tráfico de marihuana
se hayan desplomado, lo que ha tenidos dos
consecuencias muy claras:
(Por un lado las fuerzas de seguridad y los
tribunales han podido destinar más recursos
a combatir crímenes graves; por otro lado
ha reducido el número de personas encarceladas…
por delitos como el consumo que no afectaba
a nadie.)
Tal cual como lo escucháis, podemos decir que en los estados que han apostado por la legalización, la
cultura de la violencia, que es un problema
bastante grave en este país, se ha reducido.
Y por si no fuese suficiente, encima, la legalización
hace que esta actividad ahora pague impuestos.
Así que, amigos, si Estados Unidos quiere
reducir sus altísimas tasas de consumo,
es probable que la legalización de la marihuana
sea una buena, pero que muy buena idea.
Por una lado vierte luz sobre un negocio hasta
ahora muy opaco, al tiempo que permite que
el producto gane en seguridad y que existan
más controles.
Además las autoridades pueden destinar el
dinero obtenido por los impuestos de esta
industria a realizar campañas de concienciación
y campañas sanitarias, algo que, por cierto
en Portugal dio muy buen resultado… pero
de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo.
El caso es que tal vez por todo esto… las
encuestas nos muestran que más del 60% de los
estadounidenses son partidarios de la legalización.
Al tiempo que cada vez son más los estados que anuncian su intención de legalizar la marihuana,
no solo para uso médico sino también para uso
recreativo..
Algo que por cierto… empieza a ser ya una
tendencia.
Fijaos, en 2013, Uruguay se convirtió en el primer
país del mundo en legalizar la producción,
distribución y consumo de marihuana.
Aunque eso sí, de una forma muy regulada.
Este año, en 2018, todo apunta a que Canadá
va a seguir sus pasos.
Al menos, esa es la promesa de su Primer Ministro,
Justin Trudeau.
Por cierto, como curiosidad, en las bolsas de
Canadá cotizan unas 80 empresas relacionadas
con el cannabis.
Pues bien, en 2017 se revalorizaron ni más
ni menos que un 250%.
NO está mal ¿Verdad?
Una industria nueva está creciendo.
(“Una nueva industria en la que entre otros,
el conocido inversor Peter Thiel, del que
ya hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik, está
apostando fuerte a través de la sociedad
canadiense Privateer Holdings que, por ejemplo,
está poniendo en marcha en Portugal la mayor
plantación de Marihuana de toda Europa”.)
En fin amigos, así están las cosas.
Pero ahora turno para ti ¿Eres partidario
de la legalización de la marihuana?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.